dai primi dati rivelano e non solo
condito i sei sicuro che sia l'unico
modo quel certo se vuoi diventare
veramente famoso devi di stare i rapper
più famosi dai verdi ben capito salmon
fabri fibra o poi capiranno che lo dico
io derby ho capito però io non so
neanche che canta non so cantare ma
scusami non so you tube e si e ancora se
cantare dai capi maroni e semi denuncia
ma meglio che ci fa l'articolo roll it o
dai forza
io ho le mie palline le palline vere le
ho date io sono rimasto con se foste
robe terribili va beh un po di un po di
trash ce l'ho anch'io tipo questi questo
no no ragazzi
ma è vero che sembrava più vecchio di un
pochino sì che i capelli che secondo me
sonorizzare beni barba però presentato
un attimo a chi non ti conosce perché
poi rompono le balle
quindi ora giustamente mi vedete che
kaki chiesto perché giustamente sono
shade sono un rapper ma anche youtuber
dipende da quanto vogliate insultarmi
alcolemia di colazione youtuber in modo
offensivo non piena mi offende molto a
proposito di quella cosa lì tra l'altro
perché effettivamente come ti dicevo
prima ho avuto questa crisi di mezz'età
dove ha 28 anni ho iniziato ad ascoltare
il rap e ci sta e non ci sta
assolutamente che io ho visto che ho
sentito più che altro che in alcuni
testi utilizzate
se vi parlo in generale utilizzate la
frase tu non sei un rapper 61 youtuber
in modo offensivo così mi viene l'ansia
quando mi dicono che lavoro facili dico
faccio il comico sul web
certo paura se e come aldo giovanni e
giacomo quando c'è la ore in ferramenta
noi creiamo scuso e quindi tu ti senti
più leggero più ma e io quando mi
chiedono ma quindi sia un rapper dico ma
no in realtà parlo veloce bene o male
quello jazz io mi sento tutti e due c'è
un canale youtube che mi aiuta
tantissimo a veicolare la mia musica
e questa foto qua dove questa foto qua
sei tu che hai vinto in tv in tv spit
esatto che a questo contest di freestyle
realizzato da mtv su mtv quando ancora
non c'erano solo reality beceri ps ma
c'era anche della musica pensa
television era sera fighissimo perché a
differenza degli altri talent tra
virgolette era tutto vero 6 freestyle
erano veri non c'era il televoto che
magari poteva trattare e noi facevamo
freestyle esattamente come lo facevamo
ai murazzi perché tu conosci bene per
capire piuttosto che
le botte ai murazzi davanti al regio con
con anne se tutti i mostri sacri del del
freestyle italiano e volevo chiederti
anche quello quanto ha influenzato
torino per quanto riguarda il freestyle
rap guarda quando ho visto la sponda già
che stavo commuovendo quindi poi puoi
immaginare sempre tantissimo perché a
torino non c'è niente sì non c'è niente
siamo dei poveracci
già è tanto quando c'erano delle serate
di freestyle figurati etichette
discografiche radio promo cioè non c'era
nello zaino non c'era niente anni fa
questo 2008 ma io faccio come stare dal
2005 figure la mia prima gara di
freestyle e l'ho fatta lyxor conosce no
in via po col sotterraneo a impero
però allora alcuni lo chiamano xo alcuni
però il però successi ea torino la
figata da questa cioè o spacca vi nel
freestyle
non c'era modo di venire fuori non c'è
un etichetta non c'era un manager non
c'era nulla visto che tu ce l'hai fatta
vuol dire qualcosa
ti vedo come un assegno si l'assegno
teheran 5 mila euro in gettoni d'oro
come può benissimo e la cosa divertente
è che comunque non sono 5 mila euro
perché l'oro è tassato per quello che
pagano in oro i primi sono ancora tutti
lì da bravo rabbino di tutti il più
ancora 20 laner regalati un paio a degli
amici che magari mi hanno e hanno
seguito nel percorso con quel di gettoni
il grasso come quelli della sala già
bellissimo per crisi non ti conosce se
ti dovessi cercare su google che io ho
cercato shade è il primo risultato e
fisico a driver saputi prega di michele
assolutamente no questa è la ricetta
fisico e secondo prima attraverso di
essi ma adesso masi come bruce lee è una
pallina a posto
queste bellino reso più bello in questa
palla che su tutto il mio corpo tra
l'altro è vero ma non il tuo pubblico
arriva tutto da da internet da parte
dalla strada di torino non è cessato
fuori molto magari
mi ascolta ma non è quella che magari
compra il disco viene al firma copie
quelli veri fedeli arrivano da internet
non mi hanno scoperto a spit
e poi mi hanno seguito su internet e non
ti da fastidio questa cosa magari coi
colleghi il fatto che ti porti la gente
da casa tra virgolette perché in realtà
lo fanno tutti però si principali
nessuno a me non dà fastidio anzi è una
cosa di cui vado supera orgoglioso mi
dicevano l'altro giorno dei giornalisti
per la conferenza stampa del disco
mandato ma tu sei uno youtuber detto
cazzo se ne vado fiero perché avere un
canale youtube ti permette di arrivare a
un sacco di persone in tempo zero e il
mio ufficio stampa non lo fa al lavoro
che fa il mio canale youtube il mio
canale youtube ha una forza sua per cui
se io voglio dire che il 16 novembre
esce il mio disco lo dico sul canale
youtube è lo vedono un milione di
ragazzini in pochi giorni ed è
fortissima sta roba forse cantiere per
me la invidiano abiliteranno l'invidia
del bene solo in video del canale subito
lì e tralasciando un attimo il discorso
rap che vorrei riprendere dopo volevo
attaccare questo l'hai saputo tu hai una
carriera parallela e parallela o è nata
prima è parole parallela del doppiaggio
che potremo fare un episodio solo su
quello parlando con me nel doppiaggio e
lo metto anche in cima delle sera un
albero del giardino
nelle puntate precedenti del jordaens
niente è andata sono salma 21 anni e
sono felicissimo di essere qui allo show
degli ottavi non voglio chiederti cosa
preferisci ma cosa ti dà più
soddisfazione e soprattutto chiamo po
aiutato questa cosa qua il fare il
doppiaggio per il rap mi ha aiutato
molto nell'esposizione cioè quando vado
magari in radio o in determinati posti
mediatici in cui parlare bene è
importante la voce aiuta tanto poi mi ha
aiutato nello scandire le parole l'ex
tramite tutti dicono a quando vai veloce
se sei l'unico di cui capisco qualcosa
per una vera lezione è importante
anche la dizione diciamo che ci sono
programmi come jordi che per quanto sia
molto divertente dire spero che il mio
pisello faccia come questo tappo di
spumante con schizzi a me la sono persa
con alcune cose me le fanno cambiare in
corso si lo è perché sono troppo volgare
un po troppo però preferisco fare altre
cose ecco preferisco guardare
addirittura il cartone giapponese trash
si insiste non chiudono sul calcio si
chiama inazuma eleven
magari questo fumo strafamoso inesatto
però è una versione trash degli e benji
ho scoperto
ci sono dei tiri speciali per cui escono
dei pinguini dal campo e spingono la
palla in porta fermo e c'è un portiere
che fa la parata pelosa
così fa questa mossa sono tutti i peli
si chiama la parata pelosa e l'annuncio
parata penosa tesconi per i e lui para
quelli per il lavoro più bello del
numero decisamente si è spesso la parata
penosa io metto l'ultima pallina pelosa
perfetto farlo fuori fa veramente schifo
tu stai tra l'altro ritornando al mondo
del rap stai per far uscire un album
anzi no è già uscita video arriva dopo è
già il sito è già uscito io volevo
parlare di una cosa o quale le foto
degli altri due album che sono clown sas
italia e mira bilancio ma tu li conosci
ma sta roba incredibile saluto quando me
lo dici piango perché io ora mi dicono
per questo sono io il tipo che li ha
registrati
no più che altro ai un tool un grave
problema con i giochi di parole tu ma
claustrofobie mirabil ansia ma non solo
il 9 degli album perché so che poi nelle
strofe cena liquido la peggio come mai
questo problema grave è una deformazione
professionale ho iniziato questa cosa
qui per gioco con freddo con fred e
palma
lo facciamo con i nomi con i nomi delle
persone che nei giorni del presso queste
cose qua allora da lì anche nei testi
insomma ci divertiamo a fare questi
giochi di parole e sui titoli mi piaceva
che avessero appunto l'impatto di una
parola che già conosci come mirabilandia
e cambiarla e mirabilandia tante volte
mi capita di sentir dire mirabilandia
invece di mirabilandia aprile sbagliano
lì c'è addirittura il parco divertimenti
ha risentito di questa roba parco
divertimenti bellissimo rovinato per
colpa mia
e però io ho considero the two manche ad
un gioco di parole si è informata grido
mera me l'ha scritto per messaggio di
ritiro ti sei dimenticato anche altro
versato è un gioco di parole anche
quello se limitazione di ufficiale di
grido a volte facciamo j ax che poi
comunque parlano in modo molto simili
tra l'altro gi.acs ha fatto un gioco di
parole bellissimo nel mio disco
secondo me la rima più [ __ ] l'ha fatta
alcuni poi le rare sì certo non sarà già
uscite mi chiedi di uscire il sabato
sera
vadi made in palla a furia di
frequentare queste tipe su instagram
mi sono preso la sel filid e cioè se il
feeling è un gioco di parole che ho
sentito del tubo ax cia non so quanti
anni più di me però i una roba così non
l'ho mai pensato e dell'anima più [ __ ]
del disco secondo me secondo me l'anima
significa del disco la foto g sa cosa
dire e mi sento da meno perché cavolo io
mi sentivo il chi in questi giorni però
è arrivato ax vent anni più di me
mamma mese magari e influenzati un po
tutto diceva non voglio avere la
presunzione di dire no assolutamente no
per ora fuori allora un po è vero che
lui si è calato nel mondo shade per fare
il featuring commento tu ti senti quindi
così basso siamo molto simili non sapere
se siamo due falliti in realtà è davvero
natale noi siamo due persone sono
l'esempio ragazzi tanti auguri è un po
la versione di una poltrona per due per
depressi 1 xanax per due però tu sei un
po una [ __ ] sì perché tu io ti becco
ovunque pensavo le ragazze hanno l'idea
la gente lo sa se sei fidanzato proprio
perché io lo so ma magari lo sanno cosa
si fidanza te magari quando ci riuscirà
questo video santos e lovey dovey
riguarderà le scale pazzo o comunque da
quello che sembra da fuori tu hai un
buon rapporto con quasi tutti nel senso
che appunto sei una [ __ ] perché ti
vedo con da tutti o ti considerano il
fratellino minore che dice massif hanno
fatto discutere
secondo me ti dico la verità speriamo
magari io con gente come come club dogo
e marracash non è che abbiamo un
rapporto per cui andiamo a cena tutte le
sere però se ci si incontra si
chiacchiera e e loro sanno che io ci
sono da tanto tempo che faccio freestyle
da tanti anni comunque e hanno rispetto
del fatto che comunque rimanendo me
stesso facendo sempre la mia roba
nonostante sia diametralmente opposta da
loro
io abbia mantenuto una certa credibilità
e per me significa tantissimo viene il
loro rispetto
direi anche perché ho paura che mi
picchino 16 di quel tipo diretto quindi
pescara dai finestrini però qualcuno
acquisto antipatico c'è che ha il tuo
nome sul suo proiettile per caso non si
no così grave ma guardo e ridere quando
poi mi hanno visto di persona vuoi
sapere cosa hanno fatto
mi hanno fatto la pernacchia se ha
saputo sparami è meglio non mi venissero
testa a testa a dire allora invece no
invece no senti per quanto riguarda il
dissing perché è una pratica abbastanza
comune è in realtà è che fa parte del
gioco
se c'è una cosa che molto spesso la
gente forse anche forse quelli più
giovani in gioco è la parola giusta per
rack game
ecco se io volessi fissare delle persone
famose per diventare io famoso no di
salerno delle persone è per famosi chi
che non mi potrei fare se poi quel nome
ti risponde al dissing è tipo nel caso
di salmo sono soldi dipende tipo tipo ci
potrebbero veramente non mi viene in
mente nessuna gli arrivano denunce per
questo show ogni tanto non ancora avere
il milione ma dici che c'è un pelo di
vergogna come me nel dire
faccio lo youtube mi vergogno di dirlo o
c'è per loro magari dire ascolto il
rapper dopo i vent'anni e può essere una
vergogna e poca persone forse a dire ha
scorto lasciare dopo il fatto che fosse
quello fornito un problema forse il
problema sono io
grazie ragazzi siamo allora cresce
veramente brutto questo è veramente
brutto
e se mi denuncia ma meglio che ci fa
l'artico loro nido dai forza
va bene
[Musica]
fede più che fare brutto tu puoi solo
fare e rutti c'è mille tatuaggi mi fan
cagare tutti la fera in più che moglie è
solo la tua social se il passato dal
centro sociale al centro dei soci salva
se ti sento scusa ma non mi diverto la
tua copertina disegnata al mio cuginetto
guarda che non me ne frega però di
quanti streaming fighter non darteli col
premio craccato spotify ogni volta che
mi ascolto nei 23 dei sulle caviglie e
come padre per tu non riesci a far del e
nemmeno con il jazz le fai una ogni tre
anni come i dischi ma dentro la scatola
di marcio a vomitare fibra porta sfiga
non lo posso nominare
poi ti fai le serie ma ti basterebbe
momento almeno io quando le faccio non
sbaglio ad aprire un sito sono una cosa
sola costo suono un po come gli arcade
boys con i colesterolo
da quanto lo prendete in cui l'avete
anche lasciati kata ha comunque satira
[Musica]